>>> IT'S THE FIRST CALL UP IN
RUIA SINCE WORLD WAR II.
A 300,000-PERSON PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION.
VLADIMIR PUTIN TRYING TO RESTORE
HIS BATTERED FORCES IN UKRAINE
IN THE WAKE OF MAJOR SETBACKS IN
THE UNPROVOKED WAR HE STARTED.
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE HAS OUR
REPORT ON THE REACTION FROM THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: SUDDENLY, EXODUS
ACROSS RUSSIA'S BORDERS.
SOCIAL MEDIA NOW FILLED WITH
IMAGES OF THE SOUTHERN FRONTIERS
OF VEHICLES BACKED UP.
EVERYONE IS ON THE RUN FROM
RUSSIA HE SAYS.
ENDLESS CARS.
IT'S MIND BOGGLING.
IN THE WEST TOWARD FIN LAND
BORED OTHER FIGURESES ALSO
REPORTING SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
TRAFFIC.
5,000 CROSSING IN A SINGLE DAY.
MORE EXPECTED BY THE WEEKEND.
MAKING FOR THE EXITS.
ACROSS RUSSIA THERE IS A GROWING
SENSE OF ALARM.
EVEN ANGER OF THE CALL UP FOR
RESERVISTS TO FIGHT IN UKRAINE.
MORE THAN 1300 PROTESTERS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DETAINED.
MANY OF THEM WOMEN, TERRIFIED
THEIR HUSBANDS AND SONS WILL BE
KILLED.
[ SPEAKING IN NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Translator: I'VE GOT TWO KIDS
OF CONSCRIPTION AGE.
I'VE BROUGHT THEM UP ALONE.
I DON'T WANT TO LOSE THEM, SHE
CRIED.
AND FOR WHAT, ASKS HER FRIEND?
SO THEY CAN KILL THE SONS OF
OTHER MOTHERS, SHE ANSWERS.
BUT THE MOBILIZATION IS TAKING
PLACE REGARDLESS.
RESERVISTS LIKE THESE BOARDING A
MILITARY TRANSPORTER IN THE
RUSSIAN FAR EAST SHOWING HOW
MANY ARE HEEDING THE CALL TO
ARMS.
ASSEMBLY POINTS, FAMILIES ARE
SAYING EMOTIONAL GOOD-BYES
BEFORE THEIR MEN, SOME
APPARENTLY IN MIDDLE AGE, ARE
BUSSED AWAY.
IN WHAT WAS ALWAYS CAST AS A
LIMITED, SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION AND FEELS MORE AND
MORE LIKE A FULL BLOWN WAR.
DON, THE STAKES AT HOME FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN ARE RISING
TONIGHT.
HE IS CONTINUING TO RAISE THEM
AS WELL IF UKRAINE.
TOMORROW A SERIES OF REFERENDUMS
WILL BE HELD ABOUT BRINGING
AREAS OF THAT COUNTRY INTO THE
RUSSIAN STATE.
IF THAT HAPPENS SENIOR RUSSIAN